ceux engendrés par les gilet jaune
c'était samedi dernier sur les champs
elysées gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
il ya vu une manifestation de la peste
brune c'est ce qu'il a dit hier c'était
dans le grand jury rtl le figaro lci
et ce ne sont pas les gilet jaune se
manifester c'est la peste brune qui est
magnifique mais aussi wii vous appelez
ça comment des gens qui retirent des
pavés sur les champs elysées qui des
balances sont des gendarmes sont des
policiers qui frappent des journalistes
vous appelez ça comment vous appelez ça
des gentilhommes qu'il faut respecter
non christophe castaner quant à lui pour
qualifier ces débordements a expliqué
que c'étaient des séditieux qui
voulaient s'en prendre aux institutions
et que tout cela était le fait de
l'ultra droite jean-christophe buisson
vous qui avez des d amitié pour
l'histoire le rock
vous avez sans doute un point de vue sur
ce sujet est-ce que la comparaison est
justifiée ou non elle est totalement
justifiée elle s'inscrit dans une
stratégie qu'on a bien repéré et qui ne
date pas de ce week-end qui nous a
expliqué qu'en france il ya le chaos
c'est à dire le ratio national marine le
pen et emmanuel macron comme s'il
n'existait rien ni sur leur côté nenê
entre eux par coordonnera que marine le
pen entre autres avec d'appeler à
manifester sur les champs elysées bien
sur mes skis et la violence des terres
mais c'est quand même quelque chose que
la peste brune c'est les mots ont un
sens cela facebook vraiment dire les
défilés de nuremberg des années trente
du parti national socialiste allemand
qu'il y ait eu des gens d'extrême droite
dans ces manifestions c'est évident il
ya eu aussi des gens d'extrême gauche la
preuve en est qu'on ait eu quelques
slogans on a eu des drapeaux de che
guevara on a eu des des tags anarchie
des tags anti flics entier et a donc
évidemment que ce mouvement a
cristallisé aussi des gens plus plus
extrême que la grande masse des gilets
jaunes qui sont des braves gens
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les
interpellations les 103 qui ont été
interpellés lors en une heure
midi sur intel
bene avoué qu'il n'y avait aucune
personne fichée à l'extrême droite parmi
les cent ans interpellé donc il a
expliqué qu'en fait extrêmement était
venu mettre le bazar au début puis après
ils ont disparu effectivement il y avait
peut-être des gens d'extrême gauche donc
on voit très bien que le problème c'est
que la réalité revient dans le visage de
l'état qui est que ce n'est pas l'ultra
droite qui a monté ces manifestations il
ya vraiment a également un mouvement
populaire pas très bien organisé donc
sur lequel le gouvernement n'a pas de
prise il est en panique
il est dans le désarroi donc quand ils
en panique ont brandi le drapeau de
l'antifascisme parce que c'est
évidemment quelque chose d'assez
fédérateur mais ça ne répond pas du tout
aux revendications des uns des uns et
des autres et notamment des gels et
jaune on vous pose la question sur
twitter êtes vous choqué par gérald
darmanin quand il déclare que c'est la
peste brune qui a manifesté sur les
champs-elysées et vous êtes 74% à nous
répondre oui vous continuez à voter
évidemment sur twitter hashtag point de
vue arnaud son premier triano moi je
dois avouer que quand gérald darmanin
nous a dit ça hier mais qui trouve que
j'étais faisait partie des intervieweurs
j'ai trouvé ça tellement excessif que
j'ai même pas relevé mais j'ai sans
doute eu tort
et ça m'a étonné de votre part
effectivement c'est excessif
et c'est ça a été très bien dit en fait
ils cherchent à planter un décor le
décor c'est nous ou le fascisme
il le sait de le construire en france ça
leur a réussi aux dernières
présidentielles il aimerait reproduire
ça y compris aux européennes montre et
qui a rien entre les deux il s'appuie
sur la montée des fascistes ou
néofasciste en europe et c'est un
phénomène effectivement qu'on peut
constater pour dire que voilà ça déborde
partout mais il reste des forces
politiques diverses et variées et on
voit bien chez les gilet jaune que il ya
certes une sur représentation des
électeurs de marine le pen une sur
représentation de lecteurs de gens et
cochons milliards présentation très
forte des électeurs d'emmanuel macron
lui-même de fillon y compris d'une
bourrignon voilà donc c'est un moment
très des reculs alors il ya eu une
sélection qui s'est fait quand même sur
qui veut monter jusqu'à paris et qui à
paris veut aller sur les chances de
viser plutôt que à d'autres points de
rassemblement donc là ça a été un
phénomène d'entonnoir qui a fini par
effectivement concentrer les plus
déterminés on va dire mais ça reste une
expression populaire
quant aux pavés qui ont été retirés
champs elysées la démonstration a été
faite que c'était en travaux et qu'on
fait les pavés étaient déjà retiré
depuis un certain temps et que les gros
plans des chaînes infos sur sur a7 est
juste une parenthèse sur les chaînes
info on a passé la journée à voir les
images des émeutes uation champs elysées
il n'y a pas eu une image des
mobilisations en province qui
représentait 90 % du mouvement il n'y a
pas eu une image de la mobilisation de
la difficile défilé contre la violence
faite aux femmes qui avaient lieu le
même jour qui était très importante
voilà donc il ya quand même une une une
obsession d'aller chercher ce qui est le
plus sulfureux et qui sait aujourd'hui
les intérêts de la ma chronique y trouve
effectivement un nouveau cadre aux dîmes
après si je peux compléter une
exagération aussi de la violence parce
que l'ordre lors du 1er janvier ou lors
de d'autres manifestants ont changé ces
dix fois pire que ça il ya eu très peu
de vitrines brisées je sais même pas si
on a une seule brisé c'est très
spectaculaire il ya ya ya un camion qui
a été brûlé l'an passé par rapport à ce
qu'on peut voir le 1er janvier et le 31
décembre la saint sylvestre c'est rien
du tout donc leur temps emmanuel macron
avec son la marque focus là dessus bah
oui mais karl valentin il est trop jeune
pour avoir manifesté sûrement je crois
qu'il n'avait pas les problèmes qui est
justifié qu'on manifeste aujourd'hui
goûtez moi je trouve que c'est une
supercherie de politique politicienne
une manière d'instrumentaliser ces
revendications qui sont absolument
respectable et cet irrespect est
inacceptable et ne vraiment pas ce
ministre les violences ou suisses sont
une forme de respect non les violences
sont bien sûr c'est une forme
d'irrespect mais il ya une exaspération
très forte
évidemment dans le lot dans tous ces
gens qui manifestent ya des gens qui
n'en peuvent plus qu'ils n'en peuvent
plus de ne pas être écoutés s'est fait
quand même des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années que ça que c'est le cas j'ai
encore j'ai apporté plein de livres j'ai
apporté celui-là plaidoyer pour une
gauche populaire est écrit en 2007
notamment par christophe guilluy qui ne
cesse de répéter que il ya 60% des
classes des français qui sont ces
classes populaires et moyennes que
personne n'écoute
et qui n'en peuvent plus qu'ils ne
votent pas et qui souffre et qui perdent
du pouvoir d'achat année après année ces
gens là n'en peuvent plus ils le disent
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas l'heur de plaire
à monsieur macron mais que voulez-vous
en démocratie c'est la tyrannie de la
majorité c'est tant mieux construit ici
par les traîtres aux nazis qu'on va
dans leur colère au contraire on va même
la raviver il me semble alexis poulain
je me tourne vers vous en désespoir de
cause en dix ans peut-être que quelqu'un
va défendre le gouvernement sur moi j'y
étais samedi j'ai fait un reportage pour
le monde moderne
j'ai vu personne de fascistes j'ai vu
des gens venir ou ak vous sur les champs
elysées sur les champs elysées vous
pouvez regarder le reportage on était au
milieu des lacrymogènes on était avec
les gens on a vu les différentes
barricades on a vu aussi la violence le
dispositif policier qui était là pour
protéger
monsieur mâcon qu'il vienne me chercher
vraiment c'était personne ne passera la
place de la concorde est en fait dès le
matin très tôt les gilets jaunes
arrivent en disant mons était
désorganisé on va bloquer la place de
l'étoile ça dure dix minutes
là les crs était plutôt bon enfant
disent non mais attendez on va essayer
de descendre fait un cortège le cortège
se faire on laisse passer les gens et
puis arrive la première confrontation
avec la des tirs de grenade comme j'ai
rarement vu ou le l'air était
complètement dans un brouillard lacrymo
et des gens qui manifestaient pour la
première fois été assez étonné de cette
violence là même s'il de la retenue ce
qu'il faut voir là c'est le désespoir
les gens qui étaient dans la rue c'était
des travailleurs handicapés qui ne sont
pas reconnus qui gagnent 800 euros par
mois
des élèves infirmières qui avec les
mesures du gouvernement ban arrive plus
à payer leur loyer des gens qui sont
retraités qui sont là pour leurs enfants
pour aussi dire c'est pas possible
si on continue comme ça ça ne va pas
marcher c'est pas des gens qui votent
c'est pas des gens qui sont forcément
politisée qui sont là pour en découdre
avec macron c'est des gens qui disent
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'on est en
train de nous rendre ce progrès qui en
fait une régression absolue on regarde
la grande bretagne
on va sur le monde moderne traduire le
rapport du rapporteur de l'onu sur la
pauvreté en grande bretagne c'est un
pays qui a vécu un miracle libéral qui
est en train de revenir à l'ère de
dickens simplement parce que la pauvreté
c'est un choix de politique c'est à dire
qu'on destine à un moment quand la crise
de 2008 arrive de ne pas aider les plus
fragiles de ne pas aider le plus pauvre
et de faire les politiques sont les ans
pour relancer la croissance pour faire
du ruissellement qui ne servent à rien
et ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui en france
c'est quoi ces des politiques qui
servent exactement à ça c'est à dire à
faire de l'argent là où l'argent est
mais finalement ça coûte un pognon de
dengue d'aider ces gens là alors on ne
va plus les aider il va falloir qu'ils
soient responsables et qu'ils se
débrouillent tout seuls
là ils sont dans la rue pour dire on ne
veut pas de ce monde là alors si c'est
ça le progrès on veut
ce progrès là quand même il aurait pu
défiler pacifiquement ils ont défilé
pacifiquement je tiens à le dire
le livre à des provocations politiques
de casse il ya eu alors déjà aucune
vitrine
on est sur les champs elysées aucune
vitrine de casser on a eu quads et des
barricades avec bien sûr quelques gens
de l'extrême gauche avec des chiens qui
est très très contents de faire un fait
d'armes où effectivement des gens un peu
énervé mais face aussi à la réponse des
crs vous verrez sur la vidéo vous avez
une femme en fauteuil roulant qui se met
face à un camion de crs et qu'il empêche
de passer les crs descendre pour essayer
de la poussée elle reste les gilets
jaunes arrivent et finalement ils font
demi tour mais c'est des gens qui sont
désespérés
j'ai on ne va pas là dans cette rue
simplement pour dire on va aller casser
non on est là pour se faire voir et
entendre sans violence un soutien que ça
ou et 15 ans qui a plus une
manifestation en france conséquente sans
actes de violence et aux campagnes
locales vous en créez été le cas lors de
la loi travail
pourquoi les citoyens ajoute qu'il a
croisés ivan rioufol à gaver des
spectateurs de tous les camps des
observateurs comme angers a le look
avantage en terme
moi je trouve que ces pavés ça fait
quand même penser beaucoup à mai 68 que
personne n'a d'ailleurs qualifié de
peste brune à l'époque débat intéressant
moi je trouve dans ce mouvement
c'est qu'en fait on a l'impression que
c'est le contraire de mai 68
en mai 68 et étudiants et quartier latin
qui jamais ne connaîtrait des problèmes
que connaissent aujourd'hui ceux qui
manifestent sont allés à la rencontre
avec sartre leur tête les ouvriers de
boulogne billancourt pensons que ces
deux vrilles elle est d accompagner dans
leur lutte dans volonté de faire la
révolution
exactement et les ouvriers qu'est-ce-qui
nordine d'écouté brigitte du boulot
premièrement deuxièmement moi je pars la
révolution et je veux le cadre et je
veux plus de sécurité et je plusse
davantage besoin de la révolution
attendez non justement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé si vous lisez paul yonnet un
voyage au centre du malaise français qui
analyse très bien ce mouvement diem à
partir de ce moment là ses cadres là ces
jeunes là plutôt qui sont ensuite
devenus qu'ont fait les napperons fait
sciences po qui sont devenus des
journalistes qui ont fait 1 devenus des
des débats des bobos puis surtout des
gens qui font partie de l'air qui ont
considéré que c'est ces ouvriers là ce
qui était la figure tutélaire habituel
de la gauche étaient des beaufs racistes
ils ont substitué à cette figure
tutélaire traditionnel immigrés alors ça
s'est passé depuis 40 ans et qu'est ce
que disent maintenant ces gens là ils
disent écoutez le cadre que vous avez
fait voler en éclats maintenant on le
veut et c'est là toute la structure
toute la sécurité puis de la protection
que la gauche était censé apporter pour
lesquels elle était censée se battre je
la veux aujourd'hui plus bas au plus
aucun parti politique ne représentent
ces gens-là et seules personnes qui font
les bons constats mais en proposant des
solutions qui sont excusez moi mais
insupportable c'est le front national
d'une part au fait le rassemblement
national appelez ça comme vous voudrez
et d'une certaine mesure la france a
soumise mais quelle france insoumise on
en parlera pour une action isolée
puisque voir ses inspecteurs mais c'est
vrai que c'est ces perdants de la
mondialisation c'est celle votre up et
l'insultent des ministres l'insu de la
classe dirigeante c'est exactement
l'erreur qu'on fait les démocrates c'est
de traiter ces gens là comme des
untermenschen des gens qui n'ont pas le
droit à la parole comme des abrutis des
pauvres qui fument des clopes avec leur
diesel ça ne fait que renforcer un
courant de dégagisme qui est déjà
présent de sous-stations fois mais en
france les 10 % qui dans ton cas
d'importante chômage et certains choix
l'envié m'en la luge de destruction des
corps intermédiaires les partis
politiques la servir mans mais avant les
syndicats les associations font des trop
fort et des croyants la relation était
détruit quand même très nettement depuis
une quinzaine d'années et qui vont
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune capacité
d'encadrer mouvements sociaux et de
trouver un débouché il n'y a pas
d'interlocuteurs sa fonte des recettes
font autant décrié fauves et un tiers
ils ont été nuls tout selon les
associations permet vous
de donner l'impression d'avoir une
réponse politique alors qu'il n'en a pas
parce qu'évidemment si imaginons par
l'absurde qui n'est pas accusé l'extrême
droite qu'est ce qu'ils auraient répondu
à ce qui s'est passé samedi ils ont
aucune réponse et merci la création d'un
haut conseil de transition transition
mais avant je laisse la parole aux eaux
le dernier mot aux internautes
vous êtes assez partagé un le monsieur
baby nous dit la violence décrédibilise
le mouvement des gilet jaune alors que w
dit au contraire le gouvernement essaye
de nous faire peur avec la montée des
extrêmes
le problème de cette manif c'est qu'il
ya des gens qui protestent sur des
sujets très différents
voilà un autre internaute qui me disent
et il a eu beaucoup de casse nous
n'avons pas vu les mêmes images
j'imagine que si elles mêmes images que
que vous les intervenants et nicole nous
dit il est inadmissible de ne pas
immédiatement bloqué les casseurs ce qui
d'après la police peut se faire si on
leur donne l'ordre une dernière question
vous quittez surpasser l'équipement est
ce que vous avez l'impression que les
policiers ont d'abord laissé faire entre
guillemets sont pas laissés faire ils
ont été assez souple moi j'ai vu des
scènes où je me disais oh là là ils vont
taper les manifestants et finalement non
il y avait quelque chose de l'ordre de
n'essayez pas de taper pour casser le
mouvement
donc il ya eu très peu de violence
malgré ce que vous pensez le ressenti
quand vous voyez que quelques barricades
où effectivement c'était des noeuds là
d'affrontement mais la majeure partie
des gens qui étaient là fuyait ces deux
affrontements c'est-à-dire qu'ils
disaient
ces gens-là décrédibilise le mouvement
je veux pas être là donc vous aviez en
fait du reflux permanent entre les gens
qui manifestaient qui partait de la
barricade et qui revenait mais les
policiers ont finalement étaient pas
remonter ou était là où c'était le plus
dur c'était vraiment au niveau de la
place de la concorde parce qu'il fallait
pas passer
et pour cause parce que l'assemblée et
l'elysée n'était pas loin je le disais
le président de la république on l'a
appris grâce à nos confrères du journal
du dimanche
s'apprête à annoncer la création d'un
haut conseil pour le climat et alors il
va annoncer la création de ce haut
conseil
je vous dire si c'est pas une blague au
conseil national de la transition
énergétique
existe déjà donc tout ça est assez
formidable en tout cas on attend